zdf heute live am freitagabend herzlich
willkommen euch allen die bundeswehr
kehrt zurück aus afghanistan nach knapp
20 jahren ist es heute also soweit und
die letzten soldatinnen und soldaten
kommen tatsächlich nach hause landen in
diesen minuten auf dem
luftwaffenstützpunkt wunstorf in
niedersachsen dort werden wir gleich
schalten sie werden begleitet von der
bundesverteidigungsministerium von
annegret kramp karrenbauer dazu dann
auch später mehr wie gesagt wir schalten
gleich dorthin dann haben wir ein
gespräch mit ex nato general egon ramms
und mit chrysler hat gemeinsam mit dem
bundesvize markus kroth jahren das
patenschafts netzwerk für die
afghanischen ortskräfte aufgebaut und
wir sind natürlich auch sehr
interessiert daran wie aktuell da die
bewertung der lage ist eure fragen und
kommentare wie immer gerne über die
bekannten kanäle zuerst aber wie gesagt
nach wunstorf zu meiner kollegin
elisabeth schmitz die steht da schon für
uns auf dem rollfeld und die frage an
dich elisabeth ja wie ist die atmosphäre
vor ort an diesem muss man ja doch sagen
historischen tag 20 jahre nach beginn
des einsatzes
ja wirklich vor zwei minuten ist die
erste von drei bundeswehrmaschinen hier
gelandet und das ist schon ein raunen
durch die reihen gegangen ich hatte
vorab die gelegenheit mit soldaten hier
vom standort zu sprechen aber auch von
ganz deutschland die natürlich jetzt
ihre kameraden hier begrüßen und
erwarten und ich muss sagen es ist
zweigeteilt viele haben mir erzählt ja
sie ist ein riesenstein vom herzen viele
sind so erleichtert dass ihre kameraden
hier unversehrt landen werden das sind
ungefähr 350 bis 400 soldaten und
soldatinnen die hier ankommen in
wunstorf aber auf der anderen seite
haben wir auch gehört es gibt noch eine
maschine einen erzählen wir gerade wenn
es laut wird die nächste maschine landen
es gibt noch eine maschine in
afghanistan der bundeswehr das ist quasi
ein fliegendes krankenhaus das noch dort
bleibt nicht in kabul aber eben mit
deutscher besatzung und da fiebern schon
noch viele mit wir wissen alle wie auch
hier die soldaten haben die bilder
gesehen der letzten tage die anschläge
sie fiebern auch mit ihren vor allem us
amerikanischen kameraden mit man kennt
sich vor ort wurde mir gesagt also da
ist schon noch ein sehr sehr ja sie sind
alle sehr angespannt und fiebern mit bis
wirklich alle dort heil raus sind ja
also diese medizinische spitze
geben um eventuell den bündnispartnern
auch vor ort noch helfen zu können wie
es denn jetzt die tatsache zu bewerten
dass die
bundesverteidigungsministerium und ja
auch andere politiker vor ort sind sie
ja sogar die deutschen truppen in
taschkent abgeholt haben das hat ja auch
eine gewisse symbolik
absolut man muss wissen als hier ende
juni die letzten maschinen der
bundeswehr aus afghanistan gelandet sind
damals war ja der einsatz offiziell
beendet da gab es hier keinen empfangen
es war keine
bundesverteidigungsministerium hier vor
ort kein anderer politiker aus berlin
oder sonst jemand also das hat heute
eine ganz besondere relevanz natürlich
wir wissen es gab sehr viel kritik in
den letzten tagen gegen das
bundesverteidigungsministerium gegen die
bundesregierung im allgemeinen und das
heute die verteidigungsministerin nicht
nur die soldaten abholt dass sie ein
statement gibt auch wenn es in einem
kleineren rahmen ausfallen wird das soll
natürlich auch noch mal ein stück
wertschätzung für immerhin 20 jahre
afghanistan-einsatz zum ausdruck bringen
und natürlich auch es ist schon so etwas
in der luft von unsere helden kehren
heim denn wir wissen alle das war kein
einsatz wie sonst der bundeswehr der
vergangenen jahre das war ein
bewaffneter einsatz im krisengebiet also
hier will die
bundesverteidigungsministerium schon ein
zeichen setzen vielleicht auch aus dem
grund weil sie eben so sehr unter druck
stand die letzten tage und wochen wie
geht es denn jetzt heute abend dort
weiter ist denn da eine größere
zeremonie geplant oder wie muss man sich
das vorstellen
genau wir warten jetzt gerade noch
darauf dass die soldaten und auch die
verteidigungsministerin aussteigen aus
den flugzeugen dann gibt es hier eine
offizielle begrüßung es in statements
geplant heute ist die gästeliste lang es
gibt die statement der
verteidigungsministerien der
generalinspekteur die wehrbeauftragte
ist vor ort wir werden auch die
gelegenheit haben mit soldaten aus dem
einsatzgebiet zu sprechen danach wird es
aber für die soldaten noch mal ein
langer abend denn dass es auch besonders
ist eben mit dieser bewaffnete einsatz
bei anderen einsätzen dürfen die
soldaten und soldatinnen gleich zu ihren
familien in ihre arme fallen das ist
heute anders sie müssen erstmal ihre
waffen abgeben dann müssen sie zu ihren
bundeswehr standorten in ganz
deutschland gebracht werden sie werden
psychologisch auch noch mal betreut
natürlich es war ein unfassbar eindruck
starker einsatz und dann dürfen sie zu
ihren familien also es ist ein langer
abend hier auch für die soldatinnen und
soldaten die ja schon viele stunden im
flugzeug sitzen ja das klingt ganz so
vielen dank für diese ersten eindrücke
nach wunstorf elisabeth schmidt war das
für uns wir schalten später noch mal zu
euch wenn dann die
bundesverteidigungsministerium auch vor
die presse tritt vielen dank für den
moment und wir sprechen jetzt mit egon
ramms er ist nato-general ag und
ehemaliger chef der afghanistan einsatz
tobt isaf- und insofern ein äußerst
profunder kenner der materie und ich
sage einen schönen guten abend herr rams
sie können mich hören sie sitzen dort
wunderbar
rams wenn sie die bilder des abzugs
sehen der deutschen truppe nach fast 20
jahren vielleicht jetzt auch wenn sie
die bilder sehen der wieder ein
schwebenden maschinen mit den letzten
soldatinnen welche gedanken gehen ihnen
da durch den kopf
wenn man fast vier jahre für den einsatz
bei häuser verantwortlich war wenn man
weiß wie sich afghanistan in der zeit
von 2002
bis 2014/15 entwickelt hat um das selber
miterlebt zum teil dann denkt man doch
sehr kritisch über die situation nach
jetzt wurden die schnelle an abzugs der
beiden entstanden ist und auch den sehr
schnellen abzug der möglicherweise nicht
allen dingen gerecht geworden ist
stichwort ortskräfte die möglicherweise
hätte anders regeln
dass die sache sich zum ende noch mal
dramatisch zugespitzt hat mit der
evakuierung kooperation ist ein weiterer
punkt dabei eher einen sage ich mal
zumindest stark zum nachdenken zwingen
können mit dem zufrieden so
der untertitel bei uns lautete heute
musste der einsatz so enden wie würden
sie diese frage beantworten musste er
dass das ist natürlich durchaus mit
einer kritischen note versehen
ich kann nicht eine kritische frage
durchaus verstehen aber das heißt dass
man wenn man darauf kommt um diese frage
stellt jetzt endlich auch das jahr 2001
2002 zurück gucken muss man sich die
frage stellen muss ob damals für den
einsatz der internationalen truppen in
afghanistan isaf die weichen richtig
gestellt worden sind und ob es
vielleicht hinterher zu einem späteren
zeitpunkt noch entscheidungen gegeben
hat möglicherweise
vielleicht auch die weichen in die
falsche richtung gestellt haben ich
denke beispielsweise an die große
verstärkung die wir den jahren 2009 10
11 gehabt haben und die beispielsweise
die anzahl der anschläge der taliban
aber auch im zivilen verluste in
afghanistan erheblich unter gesetzt
haben und nachdem die kräfte wieder
abgezogen worden sind zum ende der isaf
mission support angefangen hat haben
sich diese zahl in dramatische art und
weise wie gut ist besonders verlust
sachen zivilen menschen in afghanistan
selber haltung
für mich kann der abzug jetzt die
abzugsentscheidung von joe biden im
april sehr früh und sie ist vor allen
dingen auch mit einer wahnsinnigen
geschwindigkeit umgesetzt worden es war
ja das ziel bis zum elften september
dazu bleiben dann sind wir auch die
amerikaner wahrscheinlich mit einer
evakuierungs operationen
31 08 aus dem land raus aus neun
nationen paar tage gespart und dieser
öfter september 20 jahre nach dem
anschlag auf die twin towers ist für
mich auch ein symbolisches datum und man
sollte sich aus beruflichen
entscheidungen nicht von symbolischen
garten über innenpolitischen gründen
denken muss hatten sie denn eigentlich
während ihrer einsatzzeit also die liegt
natürlich jetzt schon einige jahre mehr
als zehn jahre zurück in afghanistan
auch irgendwie schon damals das gefühl
naja ob das hier so was wird mit dem
aufbau einer nachhaltigen am westlichen
lebensmodell orientierten gesellschaft
da habe ich so meine zweifel oder waren
sie zuversichtlich
also erstens können sie sicherlich die
aussage des ehemaligen
verteidigungsministers zu guttenberg ja
mal irgendwann gesagt hat dass eine
westminster demokratie in afghanistan
nicht aufgebaut werden kann das ist
erstmal eine feststellung die es wichtig
und vielleicht hatte man zu anfang der
isaf-mission die ziele in dieser
richtung zu hoch gesteckt dass es die
erste anmerkung dazu die zweite
anmerkung geht in eine andere richtung
afghanistan ist ein einsatz gewesen
internationale völkergemeinschaft mit
dem isaf mandat ende des jahres 2001
beschlossen worden ist und man hat sich
für diesen einsatz bestimmte ziele
gesteckt aber nur zu betrachten wäre
falsch so den gesamteinsatz gehört auch
der aufbau des landes die
demokratisierung des landes die
einrichtung einer demokratie die
verfassung dazu gehören dinge die ich
sag das mal ausbildung der menschen dazu
gehört das thema schulen krankenhäuser
gesundheitswesen
versorgung der afghanischen bevölkerung
und etliche andere punkte mehr diese
teile lagen nicht im aufgabenbereich der
soldaten soldaten haben egal von welcher
nationen weit überwiegend ihre
militärischen aufträge erfüllt und die
frage die entscheidende frage dabei ist
was hat in dieser zeit die politik
gemacht was ist passiert mit blick auf
wirtschaft was ist passiert mit blick
auf die entwicklung des landes
demokratisierung und dergleichen mehr
und ich glaube dass bei dieser
aufteilung der aufgaben einmal der
militärische teil der nicht immer so mit
20 bis 25 prozent des gesamteinsatzes
beziffere das heißt 80 ist 75 prozent
sind dann der zivile wiederaufbau
demokratisierung bildung und dergleichen
mehr und da muss man sich dann die frage
stellen ob bedarf 60 in diesem bereich
das erreicht haben was wir uns
ursprünglich mal vorgenommen also zurück
zum thema bis ins der demokratie das war
eine vorstellung in diese vorstellung
konnte nicht eingelöst werden
er hat auch in den nächsten wochen noch
oft gestellt werden hat man sich
übernommen wie hätte man es eventuell
anders organisieren müssen aber wenn wir
jetzt mit ihnen noch mal über den
militärischen aspekt sprechen hat denn
die militärische führung der nato die
kampfkraft der afghanischen armee am
ende dann doch überschätzt der armee
überschätzt und der taliban unterschätzt
wie würden sie das beurteilen also der
taliban unterstützt ist in jedem fall
richtig die aussage das hat man auch
gesehen und die lagebeurteilung aus den
letzten monaten auch aus den letzten
tagen oder wochen wo ja niemand damit
gerechnet dass die taliban innerhalb
kürzester zeit
provinzhauptstadt nach provinz
hauptstadt einnehmen würden und dann
anschließend auch kabul mit einer sehr
großen geschwindigkeit im prinzip den
taliban in die hände in die hände
gefallen ist man muss aber wenn man
dieses thema betrachtet muss man
vielleicht ja oder andere seite jahre
zurück man muss vielleicht gucken auf
den februar 2020 wodurch die therme
administration dieses abkommen wenn
geschlossen worden ist jedes jahr ohne
alle konditionen für die taliban
abgeschlossen wurde gegründet wurde mit
dem abzug der praktisch zum ab zumal
dieses jahr statt den leute das war so
vorgesehen wie gesagt mit taliban waren
keine koalitionen verbringen und hoffen
dabei nachdem dieses abkommen
abgeschlossen war haben die taliban in
afghanistan selber ich sag das mal
vorsichtig mit regional gouverneuren
möglicherweise mit der armeeführung
möglicherweise metallen der
zentralregierung offensichtlich
bestimmte übereinkommen geschlossen und
diese über einkommen haben nach meiner
auffassung ermöglicht dass die taliban
so schnell voran marschieren konnten und
sie haben möglicherweise dazu geführt
dass die armee in großen teilen die
waffen niedergelegt hat und das teil der
regierung ja ich sage das auch mal
positiv relativ schnell das land
verlassen haben aber wenn ich dann noch
mal ganz kurz ein haken darf sie würden
schon also auf dem standpunkt stehen
dass man es nicht hätte wissen können
dass die taliban tatsächlich dann
militärische so schnell so erfolgreich
sein würden weil es ja doch auch immer
wieder stimmen gibt die sagen na ja das
hätte man eigentlich schon wissen können
aber vielleicht sind diese informationen
auch nicht durchgedrungen an die politik
zum beispiel hier bei uns oder auch
nachbarn schenken weil da irgendwie
unterwegs geschlampt wurde wie bewerten
sie das nochmal zurückkommen die taliban
haben wir zirka anderthalb jahren
spätestens vor einem jahr angefangen mit
wichtigen persönlichkeiten im land
diesbezüglich verbindung aufzunehmen und
haben offensichtlich mit diesen personen
regelungen vereinbart wie mit dazu
geführt haben dass die taliban jetzt so
schnell gewinne erzielen konnten um vor
unten konnten da kommt noch ein anderer
gesichtspunkt dazu den letzten tagen wie
eine andere berichterstattung gegeben
aus afghanistan wo beispielsweise sehr
gut ausgebildete einer spezialkräfte vor
den taliban die waffen gestreckt haben
weil sie
vela munition noch viel überraschen noch
hatten sie betriebsstoff für ihre
fahrzeuge das erklärt auch das bild war
wo man die taliban jetzt auf gut
ausgerüsteten modernen fahrzeuge fahren
sieht man auf diese art und weise
natürlich auch die geländegewinne
dadurch erleichtert worden vorher sind
sie mit zwei motorrädern oder zu fuß
gegangen und sie konnten sich dann der
ihnen in die hände gefallen ausrüstung
bedienen bei dieser spezialeinheit von
denen ich gerade gesprochen habe ist
dann hinterher noch folgendes passiert
diese soldaten haben ihre waffen
niedergelegt und zum anschließen von den
taliban liquidiert worden ob das der weg
ist wie man auch noch kriegsvölkerrecht
oder dergleichen mehr mit anderen
soldaten umgehen dann mach ich mal ein
persönliches verhalten ja also mit
sicherheit nicht aber weil sie gerade
gesprochen haben von handeln oder eben
auch vereinbarungen getroffen worden
sind von den taliban mit lokalen
politikern es ist ja auch immer wieder
vom großen thema korruption die rede was
glauben sie welche rolle hat die
bestechlichkeit der die käuflichkeit von
lokalen politikern auch gespielt für den
erfolg der taliban
ich bin fest von überzeugt mit
sicherheit eine große wir lassen nicht
aber auch noch mal einen bestimmten
zurück wir haben im jahre 2009 zusammen
mit dem damaligen kommen mit christel
eine sehr detaillierte strategische
analyse gemacht und wir haben damals
festgestellt die wartung unter anderem
eine kommando- behörde in grundzügen wir
haben festgestellt dass korruption in
afghanistan eine große rolle spielt und
die amerikaner wollten sich mit
speziellen kräften gerade auf diese
korruptionsbekämpfung konzentrieren sie
haben da was deutschland gefragt ob sie
mal diese aufgabe mitmachen deutschland
hat da was die teilhabe abgelehnt weil
dieses sicherlich zu recht von
deutschland perspektive her gerade
militärische aufgabe ist und die hände
der polizei
wir warten immer noch auf das statement
der bundesverteidigungsministerium haben
gerade schon bilder gesehen also die
maschinen sind eingetrudelt in wunstorf
aber wir haben natürlich gerne noch die
zeit auch für sie um noch weiter auch
über die rolle des militärs
beziehungsweise auch der nato in
afghanistan zu sprechen eine frage auch
unseres zuschauers ismael 04 über
youtube meine frage schon mal vorab
warum hat deutschland nicht wie frank
schon im mai mit der evakuierung der
ortskräfte begonnen erst evakuieren dann
abziehen müsste doch die devise lauten
jetzt sind sie kein politiker aber
vielleicht haben sie auch eine meinung
dazu ich glaube
ich gehöre mit zu gehen die aus
erstunterzeichner diese petition
unterschrieben haben wo wir da gefordert
haben viele menschen gefordert haben wie
holz kräfte aus afghanistan also wir uns
unterstützt haben aus afghanistan raus
zu gehen das ist anfang mai gewesen und
wenn man diese petition damals
berücksichtigt hatte und zu dem
zeitpunkt mit planung auch mit
transporten bereits angefangen hätte
dann wäre die situation jetzt vielleicht
nicht so kritisch gewesen
welches sind die lehren ihrer meinung
nach die die bundeswehr aber auch
vielleicht die nato insgesamt aus dem
einsatz in afghanistan
ziehen sollte auch im hinblick auf
andere einsätze zum beispiel in der
sahelzone
ich möchte das nicht beschränken auf
nato oder auf bundeswehr so ich möchte
dass drei ausweiten allgemein auf die
internationale organisationen allen
fahren die vereinten nationen und ich
möchte das auch ausweiten auf den ganzen
internationalen bereich wenn man einen
solchen einsatz vor ort und einen
solchen einsatz erfolgreich beenden will
dann muss man sich vorher einen
masterplan erarbeiten als solchen
masterplan ich sag mal gemeinsam
zwischen obama und leiser oder unama
nato vereinbart dass für afghanistan nie
gegeben wir haben alle deutschland vom
vernetzten ansatz nato vom konkurrenz
ist groß die vereinten nationen vom
integrierten coach gesprochen um
deutlich zu machen dass dies eine
komplexe gesamte operation ist aber in
dieser komplexen gesamte operation hat
es nie einen strategischen plan gegeben
das ist auch jemand die gesamte
operation geführt
heran sie stehen uns noch zur verfügung
vielen dank schon mal für das gespräch
bis hierhin wir wollen gerade nochmal
auf die tagesaktuellen ereignis zu
schauen gestern nachmittag also war es
als sich ein selbstmordattentäter am
flughafen in kabul in die luft gesprengt
hat mindestens 100 menschen wurden in
den tod gerissen mehr als 160 verletzt
was man inzwischen sonst noch darüber
weiß dass berichte glück war pott
sie sind mit dem leben davon gekommen in
den krankenhäusern kabuls werden
dutzende verletzte versorgt die sich
gestern in der nähe des anschlags auf
die explosion hat mich in den
abwasserkanal geschleudert da lagen
bestimmt hundert leichen erfassen den
ganzen tag über wurden särge von opfern
abtransportiert die das attentat nicht
überlebt haben und vor den
krankenhäusern haaren verzweifelte
angehörige aus mein mann legt den
kritischen zustand auf der
intensivstation hier er ist sehr schwer
verletzt sein bauch der rücken die beine
alles in schlimmen zustand
am flughafen tor wo ein
selbstmordattentäter gestern so viele
menschen grausam ermordete herrschte
heute stille im netz bekannte sich ein
ableger des selbsternannten islamischen
staates zu dem anschlag die es
terroristen hatten schon in der
vergangenheit zahlreiche blutige
anschläge auf schulen und krankenhäuser
in afghanistan verübt sie bekämpfen auch
die radikal islamischen taliban denen
sie vorwerfen kompromisse mit den usa
eingegangen zu sein ein taliban-sprecher
erklärte die verantwortung für den
anschlag trügen die usa und deren
verbündete
sie haben die menschen zur ausreise
ermuntert und sie bewachen den
gesperrten flughafen für uns ist es sehr
schwer 10.000 menschen vor dem flughafen
zu kontrollieren das ist ein großes
problem
die meisten staaten haben inzwischen die
evakuierungsflüge eingestellt mehr als
5300 menschen flug die bundeswehr aus
kabul nach taschkent 300 deutsche halten
sich aber noch in afghanistan auf sie
konnten später ausreisen so die
zusicherung der taliban wenn der
linienflugbetrieb in kabul wieder
aufgenommen werde darüber verhandelt die
türkische regierung derzeit mit den
taliban der ausgang ist ungewiss auch
eine ausreise über den landweg wird
erwogen die grenzen wie hier nach
pakistan sind allerdings von den taliban
bewacht tausende afghanen drängen sich
seit tagen an den übergängen in der
hoffnung das land doch noch verlassen zu
können
und wir warten noch auf das statement
der
bundesverteidigungsministerium sprechen
jetzt aber zunächst weiter mit kinect
sei der gemeinsam mit dem bundeswehr
offizier markus kroth jahren das
partnerschafts netzwerk für die
afghanischen ortskräfte in afghanistan
aufgebaut hat uns zugeschaltet aus
magdeburg erst mal einen schönen guten
abend herr
guten abend wie es denn die aktuelle
situation für die von ihnen betreuten
menschen haben sie momentan noch kontakt
gerade nach den ereignissen von heute
beziehungsweise gestern kann man sich
das ja noch kaum vorstellen wie wie ist
es
ja die situation ist leider
schrecklich in kabul für die ortskräfte
heute hatte ich den ganzen tag kontakt
gab mit den aus kräften mit den
zurückgebliebenen aus kräften die sich
jetzt gerade in kabul aufhalten und
irgendwie versuchen sich zu verstecken
kinder von denen aus kräften sind krank
aber sie trauen sich nicht zum arzt zu
gehen weil sie sich nicht auf der straße
zeigen dürfen wie können sie da im
moment aus deutschland helfen fragt man
sich doch was können sie jetzt moment
sie sind uns zugeschaltet aus magdeburg
tun um den menschen dort irgendwie hilfe
zu sein um die eine orientierung zu
geben oder einfach auch praktische tipps
zu geben
ich bin ständig in kontakt mit den
aufschriften sie stellen viele fragen
sie frage mich wie es mit denen
weitergeht aber natürlich wie es mit ihm
weitergeht entscheidet die
bundesregierung und das auswärtige amt
die entscheidung können wir leider nicht
treffen aber ich bin natürlich für die
ortskräfte am telefon da ich höre zu
ihre sorgen ihre fragen und versuche es
natürlich durch die medien vermitteln
und die bundesregierung aufmerksam zu
machen dass die bundesregierung schnell
wie möglich eine einer lösung für diese
menschen die sich gerade in kabul
verstecken anbietet ja ich muss da
gerade noch mal nachfragen sie führen ja
eben auch listen über ortskräfte haben
sie schon erkenntnisse darüber ob jetzt
bei dem anschlag irgendjemand zu schaden
gekommen ist der auf dieser liste stand
zum glück nicht aber es waren natürlich
ortskräfte die an dem tag am flughafen
nicht ahnen und gewartet haben dass sie
irgendwie rein zu kommen man rein zu
schaffen aber sie hatte natürlich
abstand und sind sie zurück nach hause
gegangen und mit kindern mit familien
und es gibt vielerorts crafter die ein
visum haben ja über 70 ortskräfte die
ein visum und der hand haben aber
trotzdem das nicht geschafft haben zum
flughafen zu kommen und mich erreichen
pro stunde unter der anruf war von den
kräften jetzt gerade über 1000
ortskräfte verstecken sich gerade in
kabul und warte nur ab bis die
bundesregierung eine schnellere lösung
anbietet ja wir haben weil sie gerade
davon sprechen ein ganz konkretes
beispiel gefunden für eine orts kraft
die es bislang eben nicht aus kabul
geschafft hat den namen den dürfen wir
aus sicherheitsgründen nicht verraten
wir können auch das müssen wir der
ehrlichkeit halber sagen nicht zu 100%
nachprüfen ob die geschichte die uns
dieser mann erzählt hat stimmt aber nach
allem was wir nach prüfen konnten halten
wir sie für glaubwürdig also so
glaubwürdig jedenfalls dass wir sie euch
zeigen wollen
es waren mehr als sechs jahre die ich
für die bundeswehr als fernsehreporter
gearbeitet habe von januar 2015 bis juni
anfang mai 2021 habe ich es versucht und
mein asyl an die bundeswehr gesendet
als allererstes haben sie mich ignoriert
weil ich nicht zugelassen bin
letzten dienstag habe ich einen anruf
von der bundeswehr bekommen wir werden
dir eine e mail schicken die
gleichzeitig auch eine bestätigung zur
evakuierung ist dort ist auch ein
spezieller punkt wo ich ein bus konvoi
finden würde der zum flughafen fährt ich
war wirklich glücklich und habe das
getan dort waren zwei deutsche die
dokumente überprüfen
ich habe ihnen die idee gezeigt von der
bundeswehr bekommen ich hatte auch mein
pass in der hand den haben sie nicht
überprüft sie haben dann getragen wie
heißen sie ich zeigte ihm die e mail die
ich bekommen habe der meine bestätigung
zur evakuierung steht
dort war auch ein anderer deutscher
militärpolizist der die sachen auch
überprüft hat er hat nicht mal meinen
pass bekommen er hat nur noch an meinen
namen gefragt ich habe ihnen gesagt ich
heiße
er hat dann 456 seiten schnell
durchgeblättert und mir gesagt dein name
ist nicht auf der liste ich habe ihnen
gesagt bitte sehr ich war ein tv
journalist habe auch für die bundeswehr
gearbeitet er hat mir nicht mal zugehört
bin nicht die gelegenheit gegeben eine
minute zu sprechen er hat einem anderen
deutschen die anweisung gegeben mich mit
meiner familie raus aus dem flughafen zu
bringen was sie getan haben als
sich raus aus dem flughafen behindern
das excel geht habe ich einen anderen
anruf von der bundeswehr bekommen das
ist ein großer fehler der soldaten war
dass sie mich rausgeschmissen haben ich
habe ihnen gesagt dass ich genau vor dem
exit geht den wenn es möglich ist fragt
sie ob sie mich rein holen können sie
haben mir gesagt dass das nicht möglich
sei ich solle zum baby geht gehen
das klingt furchtbar denn das war ja das
geld wo der anschlag passiert ist
offensichtlich ist er aber nicht dort
gewesen herrn act sei also wir haben
gerade die schilderung gehört das klingt
alles sehr dramatisch und letztlich ja
auch irgendwie so als heißt dann am ende
vom zufall abhängig ob dann gerade der
beamte einen weiter lässt oder eben
nicht was was sagen sie leuten wie ihm
wie wie können sie es nochmal solchen
menschen helfen die müssen ja wirklich
am rande der verzweiflung sein oder
schon darüber hinaus
ja das ist sehr hoch dramatisch es gibt
ortskräfte die gesagt dass sie ein visum
und er hat haben und sich dann am
flughafen vor dem baby geht und auch vor
dem nord geht und die hat mir am telefon
erzählt dass sie ihr visum gezeigt haben
ihr pass gezeigt haben gesagt hier wir
haben ein visum wir haben ein pass wir
sind antragsberechtigt lasst uns ein
paar ein aber die amerikaner soldaten
konnten die ortskräfte leider nicht
reinlassen und manche von den worten
durch die taliban auch geschlagen von
gefiltert und dann haben sie den
flughafen verlassen und wieder trocken
nach hause gegangen und ja es war sehr
sehr schwer einfach in den flughafen zu
kommen ja in der tat wie schätzen sie
die lage jetzt ein netzteil wird es denn
möglichkeiten geben auch nach dem abzug
der westlichen truppen für sie
ihren leuten dort vor ort noch zu helfen
gibt es da realistische perspektiven die
menschen außer landes zu bekommen
ja die die lage ist sehr sehr schlimm in
afghanistan gerade wie gesagt die
ortskräfte verstecken sich in kabul und
aber ich hoffe dass die bundesregierung
bald wie möglich eine schnellere lösung
für dieser menschen anbietet ja ich
unterstütze natürlich die ortskräfte wir
helfen die ortskräfte wir sind für die
ortszeit statt da die höheren orts kraft
dazu ja aber wir können leider nichts
machen dass die entscheidung trifft
natürlich das auswärtigen amt und die
bundesregierung das trägt die
verantwortung eine schnellere lösung
lisa menschen als
mister
36 wenn ich das richtig aussprechen über
youtube fragt ist denn bekannt wie viele
ortskräfte es nicht geschafft haben also
noch dort sind können sie dazu noch mal
was sagen
ja sehr gerne heute habe mich über 1000
ortskräfte erreicht ich bräuchte und
erreichen mich 100 sprachnachrichten
nachrichten anrufer und die die auch ein
visum haben dann die die auch kein visum
haben aber antrags und richtig sind ja
mit bass oder passt ja und jetzt über
tausende ortskräfte verstecken sich in
kabul und versuchen sich irgendwo
aufzuhalten ja und sie haben nichts zum
essen sie haben nicht zum trinken manche
schlafen im park weil sie aus anderen
städten nach karben geflüchtet sind aus
meiner sicht die aus kundus aus dach hat
sie haben alles weggelassen weil sie
dort hatten und nach ihrer heimat stehen
können sie auch nicht erklären weil weil
ihr leben extrem bedroht ist und in
kabul versuchen sie sich irgendwie in
der bevölkerung untertauchen morgen eine
neue rückmeldung von der bundesregierung
bekommen ja also sie haben schon gesagt
die bundesregierung ist er jetzt im
prinzip in der verantwortung was raten
sie denn den leuten die sich bei ihnen
melden ganz konkret was sagen sie den
ich sage es zudem dass sie geduld haben
dass sie
auf sich aufzupassen auf ihrer kinder
und ich mir leid ich bin auch in
deutschland und ich kann den leuten
nicht irgendwie anders helfen und ich
kann nur durch die medien die
bundesregierung aufmerksam zu machen
dass die menschen in einer sehr
dramatische lage sind in kabul und sie
schnell wie möglich geholfen werden
gerettet ja ja sie versuchen darauf
aufmerksam zu machen und da kann man ja
nur sagen das ist ja heute abend
zumindest mal eine gelegenheit das zu
tun
vielleicht manchmal zum abschluss auch
die frage an sie was sagen ihnen die
ortskräfte inwieweit fühlen die sich im
stich gelassen inwieweit sind die
enttäuscht auch vom westen von
deutschland im besonderen gerade die
ortskräfte die eben mit der bundeswehr
zusammen gearbeitet haben
die enttäuschung sieht leider sehr sehr
groß aus und
manche von denen haben die hoffnung
verloren und viele fühlen sich auch
zurückgelassen und es gibt auch zwei
minderjährige kinder die zwei töchter
eine orts kraft die familie die eltern
sind schon in deutschland aber die zwei
kinder die zweijährige tochter
waren zwei wochen lang am flughafen
gewesen und wollten ihr einkommen ihren
namen nicht dann auch die alister vom
auswärtigen amt aber sie könnten es
leider nicht schaffen in den flughafen
reinzukommen wenn jetzt die sind in
kabul ohne eltern die eltern sind in
deutschland aber die kinder in
afghanistan und das macht mich total
natürlich traurig und ich versuche am
telefon für die ortskräfte da zu sein
und ich hoffe dass die bundesregierung
natürlich irgendwie einen weg für dieser
menschen spendet
snack zeit war das mit ziemlich
bewegenden schicksalen er hat gemeinsam
mit dem bundeswehr offizier markus
grothe an der ja auch des öfteren jetzt
im fernsehen zu sehen war das
partnerschafts netzwerk aufgebaut für
die afghanischen ortskräfte alles gute
vielen dank und viel erfolg für ihre
weitere arbeit danke schön und
wir warten nach wie vor auf das
statement der
bundesverteidigungsminister in wir haben
vorhin ein sehr informatives gespräch
wie ich fand mit egon ramms dem
nato-general ag und ehemaligem chef der
afghanistan-einsatz truppe isaf und ich
hoffe dass wir ihn immer noch hören und
er uns noch hört dann würde ich nämlich
gerne noch mal mit ihm sprechen und
jetzt da sehe ich ihn auch wieder
wunderbar heraus wir haben gerade die
schicksale gehört jungs
geschildert hat
beschämt sie das in gewisser weise als
angehöriger der bundeswehr sie ja
zumindest waren sie fühlen sich mit
sicherheit immer noch so dass wir diesen
menschen so schlecht nur helfen können
ja ich glaube dass hier jeder gemacht
haben die situation obwohl
ich damals
oder problem ließ und zu hause nach
deutschland jetzt ist
das große ziel gewesen und haben halten
versuchte mit nachbarn zu geben
werde ich schauen in diese richtung
wir beginnen
vielleicht ein bisschen zu spät war sie
noch zeitgerecht vor dem rhein gereist
vor dem heutigen tage ist dann wohl die
operation müssen wir eingestellt
das ist nicht nur bedauert wird oder das
ist schlecht weil diese leute auch
vertrauens uns gehabt um dieses
vertrauensvorsprung ist wir sehen jetzt
jedenfalls bilde ich weiß nicht ob sie
die aussehen können herr rams von
soldaten offenbar soldatinnen und
soldaten die über das rollfeld gehen die
wiederkommen mit schwerem gepäck unsere
kollegin elisabeth schmidt hat vorhin
gesagt die waffen müssen jetzt
also das gefühl wir doch okay ich glaube
jetzt sollen sie mich wieder also die
ist jetzt der weitere verlauf die
einsatzkräfte kommen zurück was passiert
jetzt vor ort
die soldaten in gefahr
soldaten fahren sie dann zurück in ihre
heimatstadt wieder geschafft was wird
vermutlich jetzt musste passieren
relativ schnell war vor das wird auch
geschlagen schon vor dem super von
diesen maschinen und munition
geschlechtern getrennt werden munition
durch die separate transportiert werden
dass die waffen sind produktions frei
ich weiß nicht gar nicht übersehen in
der breite ist noch irgendwelche
formalitäten abzuleisten sind für diese
soldaten aber ich gehe auch davon aus
dass ich irgendwo antreten werden um
sich nach diesen gemeinsamen der einsatz
half untereinander zu verabschieden und
möglicherweise auch
eine ausführung der
verteidigungsminister und wo es
zumindest die das unmittelbaren
vorgesetzten war diese und das bin ich
eure general zu hören wir sind
sicherlich dann doch
wo wird die soldaten gerade alle da
beieinander sehen das war in der letzten
zeit auch immer mal wieder thema das
sich doch viele die mit der truppe zu
tun haben sorgen darüber machen dass die
stimmung doch schlecht sei und immer
schlechter würde das die belange der
soldaten nicht ausreichend gehört worden
seien in den letzten monaten was hören
sie da aus der bundeswehr wie würden sie
die stimmung nach diesem einsatz
beschreiben
also ich könnte mir vorstellen dass die
soldaten in afghanistan im einsatz
gewesen sind auch jetzt aktuell die
letzten zum dreißigsten sechster zurück
gekommen sind
darunter persönlichkeiten haben dass
dieser einsatz also schnell sein war und
das ist man wie möglicherweise in einer
situation ist wo man letztendlich mit
den ergebnissen nicht zufrieden sein
kann
den ausgang afghanistan habe einen
gewissen wegen einer normalen regierung
geworden wäre wäre diese stimmen uns
sicherlich anders aber ich kann mir
vorstellen dass alle und 60.000 deutsche
soldaten in den vergangenen 20 jahren in
afghanistan im einsatz waren sicher
darüber nachdenken so ein satz ich will
oder vielleicht ergebnis war
da spielen soldaten alles sagen dass sie
ihre aufträge erfüllt haben das ziel das
was an sie herangetragen worden ist ihr
macht noch ein bisschen zum einsatz ist
ein lebens bis 59 nur durch die soldaten
in afghanistan gestorben sind gefallen
beziehungsweise schauen sind daher an
die soldaten alle ihr bestes geben und
alle anderen dass ihr vorhin schon
angedeutet habe in der politik für die
fragen dieses besondere das
kräuterbeet über youtube fragt uns wie
wird amerika jetzt reagieren trauen sie
sich da eine antwort zu also gemeint ist
natürlich die reaktion auf den
terroranschlag bei dem ja auch
mindestens so 13 glaube ich us soldaten
gefallen sind also das wird amerika
erfahrungsgemäß nicht einfach auf sich
beruhen lassen diesen vorgang sondern da
wird es eine antwort geben was glauben
sie wie wird design
relaunch präsident hat sich der
diskussion bestimmt la rosa also ja
sagen dass er diese terroristen das
gemacht haben verfolgen wird und was man
sich auch finden will das möchte ich ja
wussten diese träger ausüben und das ist
es einen ball von isis oder die es in
afghanistan möchte man gerne schmecken
verfolgen und zu recht geschafft
von daher also wenn ich gemeint ist
davon auszugehen dass die amerikaner mit
geheimdiensten aber speziell werden
diese gruppierung entsprechend zu
bekämpfen ich glaube trotzdem dass
gerade die drücken können wir gar nicht
soldaten dass gäste sind da ist in
amerika wenn man ja gefolgt um selber
eine durchaus geringer die bestimmung
aus zu müssen werden das ist sicherlich
ordentlich dabei aber insgesamt mit
diesen abschluss des einsatzes in
afghanistan nach 20 jahren in amerika
ja auch das mit sicherheit noch eine
frage die in den nächsten wochen eine
große rolle spielen wird wie wird in
amerika dieser ganze einsatz bewertet
werden und wie ist die reaktion jetzt
eben auch auf den anschlag danke für den
moment wir gucken gerade noch einmal auf
die aktuellen bilder die wir man fällt
also wie gesagt wir sind immer noch
dabei und warten auf dem
bundesverteidigungsministerium sehen
jetzt gerade nochmal die zurückkehrende
einsatzkräfte wir hatten es eingangs mit
meiner kollegin elisabeth schmidt
besprochen das ist also schon mal
natürlich auch ein großes zeichen der
wertschätzung dass annegret kramp
karrenbauer extra nach taschkent auch
geflogen ist um die bundeswehrsoldaten
die letzten aus afghanistan kommen denn
dort in empfang zu nehmen und dann mit
ihnen zurück zu kehren also das soll
natürlich schon gezeigt werden dass man
seite an seite steht kam karrenbauer die
sich ja auch in den letzten tagen sehr
nachdenklich geäußert hat was ihre
eigene verantwortung in dieser ganzen
sache betrifft so da haben wir also noch
mal weitere bilder von den
einsatzkräften und das kann man
vielleicht an der stelle auch noch sagen
auch heiko maas auch ehrlich frei von
kritik der bundesaußenminister in den
letzten tagen er will sich jetzt auf den
weg machen will bei einem besuch in der
region um
ausreisemöglichkeiten für weitere
afghanen will er sich dort bemühen er
reist also in die nachbarländer dort und
versucht dort eben auch auf politischem
wege und auf diplomatischem wege noch
lösungen zu finden wie man den letzten
verbliebenen schutzbedürftigen von denen
es ja noch einige tausend gibt wie man
denen in afghanistan eben jetzt noch
helfen kann
so und wir sprechen noch mal ein paar
takte mit egon ramms nato-general ade
ehemaliger chef der afghanistan-einsatz
truppe isaf und wir sind sehr froh dass
er heute abend zeit für uns hat
vielleicht noch mal ein thema das auch
direkt mit der bundeswehr zu tun hat der
vorsitzende der bundeswehr des
bundeswehrverbands andré wüstner er hat
der bundesregierung vorgeworfen nur
bedingt strategie fähig zu sein sie
werden das zur kenntnis genommen haben
was ist ihre einschätzung dazu
jetzt höre ich herrn rahmens allerdings
nicht noch mal ne kurze frage an die
regie konnte ich ihn jetzt nicht oder
konnten wir ihn alle nicht hören
ok jetzt haben wir gerade ein ton
problem heran ich muss ihnen leider noch
mal in die parade fahren wir müssen
gucken ob wir das beheben können wir
verstehen sie gerade nicht wollen sie
aber sehr gerne verstehen wichtige frage
es ging um die stellungnahme von andré
wüstner ich hoffe ich kriege ein zeichen
wenn der ton wieder hergestellt ist ja
wie gesagt hat der bundesregierung
vorgeworfen nur bedingt strategie fähig
zu sein ich kann gucken ob ich das noch
mal ein bisschen weiter ausführen kann
er sagte im interview mit den kollegen
von der ard die lehre aus den letzten
jahren sei das ist unwahrscheinlich
probleme gebe etwa bei der koordination
zwischen den ressorts also den
ministerien da ist einiges zu tun und
ich hoffe dass das besser gelingt in der
nächsten regierung dass seine worte noch
mal die frage wie sieht's aus mit herrn
rams verstehen wir nein wir haben immer
noch keine chance ihn zu verstehen das
ist natürlich bitter denn wir warten ja
auch immer noch auf das statement der
bundesverteidigungsministerium
ministerin pardon so aber wenn jetzt
kein gesprächspartner mehr haben dann
wäre jetzt die frage wie wir weiter
verfahren
gut wir beschäftigen uns noch mal mit
der tagesaktuellen situationen wir
schauen noch mal nach kabul auch auf die
reaktion aus den usa auf diesen
furchtbaren terroranschlag
aha jetzt höre ich gerade dass wir herrn
rams wieder hören können dann machen wir
doch gerne an der stelle weiter ramms
also ich hatte sie gefragt nach dem
statement ihres kollegen wüstner also
kollege jetzt im weitesten sinne erst
der vorsitzende des bundeswehrverbands
er hat der bundesregierung vorgeworfen
nur bedingt strategie fähig zu sein wie
ist ihre einschätzung
also ich habe dieses statement von andré
wüstner ostern andere ist gestern abend
im fernsehen gehört und ich habe ihnen
wegen seines mutes bewundert
ich glaube aber dass er mit dieser
aussage recht hat zumindest recht hat
dass krisensituationen haben geht und
wir müssen natürlich in deutschland
lernen weiter vorauszuschauen als es von
registratur prägung ist zudem gesagt
periode und wir müssen darüber
nachdenken die nicht nur bereich der
sicherheitspolitik und
verteidigungspolitik dinge so aufstehen
und windeln können dass die langfristig
bestand haben und auch langfristig
entsprechende ausrüstung und ausbildung
und gegen den die soldaten brauchen
damit sie in solchen situationen
eingesetzt werden können dazu buffet
denn das ist sicherlich ein problem
welches mehr haben werde ich sicherlich
andere demokratien auch haben weil ihr
oft von barren zu wahlen denken
langfristig den blick auf das im auge
er sagte wie gesagt dass es da probleme
gebe bei der koordination zwischen den
ressorts wie ist das aus ihrer sicht sie
haben damals als general auch als
nato-general mit sicherheit auch viel
mit bürokratischen hürden zu tun gehabt
ist das dann manchmal zum verzweifeln
oder haben sie das gefühl da im großen
und ganzen funktioniert das system
eigentlich
also die bundeswehr was die bundeswehr
angeht und nur darüber rede ich jetzt im
augenblick musste man feststellen dass
die bundeswehr ja auch blick auf diese
evakuierungsaktionen diese auch
entsprechend auf die beine gestellt hat
diese operation durchgezogen das gleiche
gilt für die auslandseinsätze gemacht
dann aber wir müssen natürlich recht da
verspricht das finde ich sag das bereit
wie viele vorschriften gesetzen
verordnungen dergleichen in diesen
fragen eingegrenzte was auf dauer nicht
gut ist wenn soldaten oder lieben einer
staatlichen vor allem einer
parlamentarischen kontrolle gar keine
frage was ist auf der seite das
widerlich sein kann und da sind bei der
bundeswehr oder bei anderen
organisationen köpfe gefordert die die
gesetze bestimmungen kennen sie
entsprechend einhalten aber auch die
handlung so müssen die spieler mit ihm
geben sie entsprechend auslassen es ist
letztendlich auch immer eine private
oder ist angesagt persönliche initiative
die handlungsspielräume die man hat so
weit aus dass im rahmen gesetze
entsprechend machen kann das musste mal
lernen dafür ausgebildet werden aber es
ist wichtig wie man dinge bewegen will
muss man diese spiele genutzt
werden odendahl fragt uns über youtube
glaube ich wir werden staaten wie katar
russland oder china reagieren bzw sich
positionieren und kann der druck auf die
staatengemeinschaft wachsen wieder zu
intervenieren
können sie mit der frage was anfangen ja
ja gar nicht fragen bin ich
ausgesprochen dankbar aus dem grunde
dankbar weil china ja eine gemeinsame
grenze mit
afghanistan hat das ist schon viel sich
70 kilometer im nordosten von
afghanistan und bei der china staats
internen in seinem eigenen land ein
problem mit mussten
zum teil ich verfolgt sie werden
umerzogen
irgendwelche vergleiche gegen mehr und
ich war mir nicht vorstellen dass die
chinesen sehr froh darüber wären wenn
der husten aus afghanistan über diese
kurze grenze nach china einziger würden
das ist aber nur einen teil der andere
dran ist hier dass dieses bereits im
jahr 2006
einen vertrag mit afghanistan
abgeschlossen haben über den abbau der
kupfer vorher der afghanistans und in
afghanistan
frank vorräte die pds außerdem wo etwa
vier bis fünf wochen verträge mit den
taliban geschlossen dass die chinesen
waren damals schon sehr weitsichtig kann
man nicht anders sagen
nämlich dahin gehen dass man in
afghanistan diktion abbauen will selbst
merten abbauen will möglicherweise ist
das energieversorgungs problem chinas
mit öl und gas
aufgrund von
afghanischen zu lösungen würden das ist
der eine befragung in china ja andere
teil das heißt schüler wird versuchen
afghanistan zu befriedigen auf das datum
war es die boden geschickt zu nutzen und
auf der anderen seite ein sag mal eine
wanderung von terroristen und auf jeden
fall zu verhindern zusammen mit der
afghanischen regierung
gegen örtliche anrainerstaaten also
punkt minister dann muss bis dahin und
tadschikistan
damals zur sowjetunion gehört haben und
dann zur gemeinschaftsaufgabe
unabhängigen staaten gehören an ein
anderes problem es gibt irgendwie
gestern war es heute eine islamische
regen ist wirklich dran also google
abgekürzt und
der usbekische staat wird versuchen das
keine terroristen über die grenze würde
gemeinsam mit bands zu nach norden
langen das spiel ist daran rhein sieg
und auf diese art und weise die eu dort
ins spital verstärken weil dann
möglicherweise die lage industrie ist
daran auch in stadt und werden könnte
die situation für
ministerrat schickes plan ist eine
ähnliche in dem falle deshalb vor
einigen wochen erst einigen gegeben der
russen gemeinsam mit diesen ländern ich
sag mal unter der überschrift wie können
wir uns gegen solche migration während
die können wir möglicherweise die grenze
wir sehen gerade annegret kramp
karrenbauer die
bundesverteidigungsminister in die sich
der presse offenbar näher zone würde ich
das richtig verstehe werden auch die
presse mitglieder schon aufgefordert
ihre plätze einzunehmen ich weiß jetzt
nicht genau wie lange diese ganze
prozedur noch dauert bis wir sie dann
tatsächlich auch hören wir sind
jedenfalls jetzt mit einem auge auch
dort dabei und sprechen vielleicht noch
ganz kurz weiter mit egon ramms sie sind
nun kein terrorismus experte aber von
jenen fragt uns über youtube müssen wir
dann in deutschland jetzt mit
terroranschlägen durch taliban diaz
rechnen haben sie das gefühl oder haben
sie informationen diesbezüglich dass die
gefahr ist gestiegen wäre
also mit den taliban auch bitte den
verschiedenen gruppierungen der partie
waren sicherlich nicht
enthalten sind darauf konzentriert ein
entsprechendes emirat in afghanistan zu
errichten und sie sind letztendlich
lokal
fokussiert auf afghanistan das heißt sie
haben kein interesse daran terrorismus
nach draußen zu tragen und sie haben
auch kein interesse daran
außerhalb afghanistans zu wird
vielleicht mit einer kleinen
einschränkung von meiner seite war
schon aus dem
radio hauptsächlich bestehen leben auf
beiden seiten der grenze zwischen
afghanistan pakistan
das heißt da können das möglicherweise
zu der ein oder andere schwierigkeit
kommen wurde die eine oder andere sache
sich anders entwickeln als die pakistan
ist vielleicht in den letzten jahren mit
ihrer unterstützung für die taliban in
erwägung gezogen haben weil diese sieht
das völlig anders aus dieses oder es ist
eine weltweit agierende
organisation die sich insbesondere auch
ich sag mal in
ostafrika aber auch in mittelafrika die
saxonen und er gar nicht mehr
bereits etabliert hat und es sollte ja
auch natürlich auf marli entsprechende
schwierigkeiten bereitet denn mein
kenntnisstand richtig ist dann sind vor
einiger zeit hier in deutschland war es
aufgrund von hinweisen die amerikaner
eine gruppe von terroristen der so
genannten spk also ein islamischer staat
provinz chorasan in deutschland
festgenommen werden das heißt mit
terrorangriffen ist jetzt muss man
eigentlich jederzeit rechnen man muss
darauf vorbereitet sein dass mit ihm
noch keine übertriebene angst oder sorge
deutschland aber wachsamkeit um dieses
zu verhindern ist in jedem fall
angebracht tja also erhöhte wachsamkeit
was auch immer das bedeutet dann im
alltag eines jeden einzelnen wir sehen
immer noch einen bundeswehrsoldaten der
dort am pult steht fahrten auf die
verteidigungsministerien die 1
redmond abgeben möchte zum einsatz in
afghanistan der heute zu ende geht nach
20 jahren das sind also die letzten
kräfte die jetzt eben in deutschland
eingetroffen sind wir haben die bilder
der ankunft gesehen das ganze in
niedersachsen und
keiner weiß genau wann die
bundesverteidigungsminister dann jetzt
ans mikrofon tritt aber es sollte jetzt
jeden moment eigentlich so weit sein wir
haben gesprochen mit egon ramms und ich
würde auch gerne mit ihnen gleich noch
mal sprechen wenn die ministerin dann
besprochen hat um vielleicht noch mal
gemeinsam auch einzuschätzen
wie jetzt die position auch der
bundesregierung die er dort dann gleich
vorgetragen wird daneben auch aus ihrer
sicht einzuordnen ist noch mal der blick
in die runde ob sie sich denn jetzt dem
pult nähert wir wissen es nicht
vielleicht hat sie auch erst mal platz
genommen der genaue ablauf ist uns jetzt
in der form auch nicht bekannt für
entstand sie dort jetzt ist zumindest da
nicht mehr zu sehen herr haben sie
wollten gerade noch was sagen
das
gespräch war es doch sein und wenn ich
das richtig sehe dann wartet die
jetzt werden aber auch sprechen wir
haben mal rein vielen dank herr amts bis
gleich
wir beginnen mit der meldung des führers
einsatzverband general art an den
befehlshaber einsatzführungskommando der
bundeswehr general pfeffer den abschluss
des appells meldet der bundes
befehlshaber der bildungsministerin der
verteidigung frau kramp karrenbauer
einheiten die mit dem einsatz waren mit
ihrer normalen bekleidung im kampfanzug
toten und ihrer persönlichen beratung
die in der andra
100 positionen beziehen sich auf stellen
es würde vermutlich darum gehen dass sie
denn die ihre plätze eingenommen haben
im ehemaligen führer dieser
gruppen die dort antreten oder
angetreten werden an dem original art
als gesamtkommandant für diese operation
in afghanistan gemeldet werden ich gehe
davon aus dass der brigadegeneral dann
an dem befehlshaber
einsatzführungskommando melden wird das
wäre ja den adendorfer
und anschließend wird die welt und die
frau ministerin erfolgen danach gehe ich
davon aus dass die ministerin dann wäre
ich komme zur sprache
wenn und soldaten das ist glaube ich die
zahl ist glaube ich die zahl jener die
ihn bei dem nivellierung sein sagt sie
nach afghanistan waren und langweilig
man hangar aufstellen und lauert was im
augenblick das geht natürlich auch in
qualität und das alles ein bisschen
schneller
informiert aber die soldaten sind in
afghanistan genießt und brot über
aufträge zu erfüllen und dann haben wir
das ganze erst dann mit sicherer hand
vorm haus
heran ich bin sehr dankbar dass sie mit
uns hier das geschehen verfolgen und es
dann auch gleichsam kommentieren ich
muss es so eben als
zivildienstleistender ehemaliger wäre
dafür denkbar ungeeignet und bin sehr
froh dass ich hier diese fachkompetenz
an meiner seite habe sie sprachen es
gerade an die
bundesverteidigungsministerium wird dann
später noch erwartet
als wenn ihnen dinge auffallen die sie
dort noch kommentieren können oder
möchten nur
zürichsee ist der jahre gerade am
rechten flügel eingetreten ist mit ein
bisschen abstand zu den gruppen die wall
street musste da will ich gar nicht
genau anhalt sollen und das ist dann
praktisch leute an den nächsten
zwischen gehörlos general art den
befehlshaber einsatzführungskommando der
bundeswehr general
für den pressesprecher bereich zu
schnell also ich halte jetzt die namen
halt und pfeffer aber die hatten sie
fielen glaube ich auch schon genannt
[Musik]
es kaum zu verstehen was dort gesprochen
wird aber es wird salutiert die haben
sich die vorgegeben so sagen darf
rechts stehen etwas unter dass ich recht
stehen und dass der generalleutnant
pfeffer würde vieles aber ein
taschengeld aber
alle mit voller bewaffnung
ja wohl darum brauche ich mich gerade
auch geplündert das zeige ich dass die
waffe nicht abgegeben werden sondern am
mann bleiben was richtig ist sie haben
keine munition dabei dass es auch hier
nicht
hier spricht offensichtlich erste käfer
das nächste sehr geehrte frau
bundesministerin kramp karrenbauer sehr
geehrter herr vorsitzende des
verteidigungsausschusses hellmich sehr
geehrte damen und herren abgeordnete des
deutschen bundestages
sehr geehrte frau wir bei aufträgen
sehr geehrter herr general zorn
sehr geehrter herr vorsitzende des
deutschen bundeswehrverbandes
oberstleutnant wüstner
kameradinnen und kameraden meine damen
und herren
als befehlshaber des
einsatzführungskommandos der bundeswehr
freue ich mich sie im rahmen des
antretens anlässlich der rückkehr des
einsatzverbandes der evakuierung
operation aus afghanistan begrüßen zu
dürfen
liebe angehörige des einsatzverbandes
ich heiße sie ganz herzlich willkommen
zurück in deutschland
für den 22 september also in wenigen
wochen ist ein offizieller abschluss
appell in seedorf geplant
angesichts der enormen strapazen denen
sie sich in den vergangenen tagen
gestellt haben möchte ich deshalb meine
worte kurz fassen
der heutige tag ist
angesichts der dramatischen lage in
afghanistan kein grund zum feiern aber
es ist ein tag zur würdigung der
erfolgreichen evakuierung von mehr als
5000 menschen ein tag zur würdigung
ihres extrem intensiven einsatzes über
nahezu zwei wochen
[Musik]
gleichzeitig ist es äußerst schmerzhaft
zu wissen dass es uns in der begrenzten
zeit nicht gelungen ist und auch nicht
gelingen konnte alle zu evakuieren die
mit oder für deutschland in afghanistan
gearbeitet haben
trotzdem
ist es ein tag der freude über die
rückkehr unserer truppen als kabul
doch diese freude wird auch massiv
getrübt durch die niederträchtigen
anschläge auf den flughafen in kabul des
gestrigen tages
wir sind zutiefst betroffen von den
bildern und nachrichten die uns erreicht
haben wir trauern um unsere
internationalen kameradinnen und
kameraden
sowie die zahlreichen zivilen opfer von
denen viele auf ihre möglichkeit der
evakuierung aus afghanistan gewartet
haben
unser mitgefühl gilt den familien sowie
den angehörigen der opfer
und unsere gedanken sind bei unseren
multinationalen verbündeten die jetzt
noch in afghanistan vor ort sind
kameradinnen und kameraden des
einsatzverbandes
trotz der tragischen ereignisse bleibt
es ein tag heute des respekts vor ihrer
leistung und des tief empfundenen dank
für ihren selbstlosen einsatz und ihre
professionalität
ohne die zusammenarbeit und die
wechselseitige unterstützung mit unseren
multinationalen partnern insbesondere
den vereinigten staaten von amerika wäre
diese evakuierung aber nicht möglich
gewesen
nur die gemeinsamen kraftanstrengungen
und das koordinierte vorgehen sowie das
entschlossene handeln der einzelnen
akteure haben diese kooperation
ermöglicht
es bleibt zu hoffen dass in den nächsten
tagen und wochen ein politischer weg
gefunden wird die weitere ausreise zu
ermöglichen
meine damen und herren verehrte gäste
in den letzten tagen wurde in der
öffentlichen wahrnehmung in deutschland
fast ausschließlich von den
fallschirmjägern und den spezialkräften
gesprochen die zu den soldatinnen und
soldaten der ersten stunde auf dem
flugplatz in kabul gehörten und somit
den gefährlichsten auftrag zu erfüllen
hatten
doch ohne die unterstützung vieler
weiterer beteiligter wäre diese schnelle
und schwierige evakuierung nicht möglich
gewesen
kernstück dieser operation war und ist
der einsatzverband in kabul der sich
zusammensetzt aus den fallschirmjägern
aus seedorf den spezialkräften aus calw
den hubschrauber teams der spezialkräfte
aus laupheim der militärpolizei aus
berlin hilden und münchen den ärzten und
sanitätern aus den verbänden des
sanitätsdienstes den einsatz kamera und
lautsprecher druck aus dem krisen
unterstützungsteam aus potsdam den
diensthunden der luftlandebrigade den
kampfmittelexperten der luftlande
pionierkompanie und dem führungsstab des
einsatzverbandes unter der leitung von
brigadegeneral alt dem ich als
verantwortlichen für die militärischen
kräfte vor ort meinen besonderen dank
für die besonnene und vorbildliche
führung der ihm anvertrauten soldatinnen
und soldaten
in dieser in vielerlei hinsicht extremen
gesamtlage in kabul aussprechen möchte
für die sicherstellung des reibungslosen
ablaufs in kabul bedürfte ist der
umfangreichen vorbereitung und
unterstützung aus taschkent in
usbekistan
diese
wurde zb durch den umschlag von bis zu
40 tonnen material an einem tag durch
die luft umschlag gruppen in der luft
land aussieht auch sichergestellt
sowie der weitere fallschirmjäger aus
seedorf
truppen psychologische militär
geistliche betreuung presse offiziere
aus potsdam die militärpolizei für die
luftsicherheit ein weiteres krisen
unterstützungsteam aus potsdam design
setzt diese flug begleitungen
materialversorgung den militärischen
führungsstab in taschkent und vor allem
die besatzungen der a400m und a350 sowie
das fliegende krankenhaus der
luftbeweglichen medizinischen
evakuierung die in gänze mit ihrem
unermüdlichen einsatz die luftbrücke von
kabul nach taschkent überhaupt erst
ermöglichten
aktuell sind noch einige kameradinnen
und kameraden des einsatzes verbandes
der luftwaffe und der streitkräftebasis
zur logistischen nachbereitung und zum
betrieb des a400m weg in taschkent diese
werden in den nächsten tagen nach
deutschland zurückkehren
darüber hinaus
er folgte eine umfangreiche
unterstützung aus deutschland und multi
nationalen verbänden heraus zu denen
unter anderem gehörten die zehnten
panzerdivision aus pforzheim die
bundeswehr krankenhäuser berlin und
hamburg die division schnelle kräfte aus
stadtallendorf
die flugbereitschaft des
bundesministeriums der verteidigung in
berlin dass die debatte jonas erfurt das
kommando schnelle einsatzkräfte
sanitätsdienst aus leer das kommando
feldjäger aus hannover das luftwaffen
truppen kommando aus köln waren des
objektschutzregiments der luftwaffe aus
schortens das logistikzentrum der
bundeswehr aus wilhelmshaven der
personenschutz ausland der bundespolizei
aus sankt augustin
der deutsche anteil des combined air
operations center in katar der deutsche
anteil des european air transport
command in den niederlanden das level
support ticket coordination center shape
in belgien und ganz besonders das hier
ansässige
lufttransportgeschwader 62
nicht vergessen möchte ich den
einsatzstab meines kommandos in potsdam
der seit dem 13 august die operative
führung der operation vorbereitet und
durchgehend gewährleistet
abschließend gilt mein nachdrücklicher
dank und persönlicher dank herrn van
thiel bis vor wenigen wochen noch
politischer berater beim
einsatzführungskommando der bundeswehr
der als vertreter des botschafters in
afghanistan mit seinem team vor ort eine
herausragende führungsleistung
vollbracht hat und stets eine enge und
reibungslose koordination mit der
bundeswehr sicherstellte
mit dieser sehr umfangreichen aber
vermutlich immer noch nicht
vollständigen aufzählung der beteiligten
dienststellen der bundeswehr und darüber
hinaus können sie einen kleinen eindruck
gewinnen was es bedeutet hat eine der
größten wenn ich die größte
evakuierungsaktion in der geschichte der
bundeswehr in solch kurzer zeit
durchführen zu können
daher
ich spreche im namen aller hier
anwesenden eine nachdrückliche
anerkennung und meinen tiefen dank aus
an alle beteiligten die dieser operation
zum gelingen verholfen augen mit
besonderem schwerpunkt dem
einsatzverband der landstreitkräfte und
den gruß der luftstreitkräfte
meine damen und herren verehrte gäste
ich freue mich jetzt den abschluss der
evakuierung operation aus afghanistan
und die bundesministerin der
verteidigung werden zu können
damit erfolgt gleichzeitig die rück
unterstellung der kräfte der
militärischen evakuierungs operation an
die division schnelle kräfte für die
aufnahme organisation hier in
deutschland
[Applaus]
was machen will
[Musik]
vor der halle stehen busse bereit um sie
zu ihrem fahrzeug zurück
so wie wir alle eine gute einreisen wir
sind wieder da wir haben uns gerade noch
mal eben die ansprache angehört von
generalleutnant pfeffer dem befehlshaber
des einsatzführungskommandos
und sprechen jetzt wieder mit egon ramms
nato-general hat der ehemalige chef der
afghanistan-einsatz truppe isaf ist
ihnen noch etwas aufgefallen vielleicht
auch bei den worten die herr pfeffer
gewählt hat herr ams- wie haben sie die
räder aufgenommen
aber das
ist ja der unmittelbare vorgesetzte
evakuierungs kontinent oder den letzten
daten für die gründung des operation
gewesen und er habe die soldaten im
prinzip ich sage es bewusst nur aber
nicht werten
auf dem fliegerhorst wunstorf begrüßt
und er hat im prinzip die soldaten aus
dieser verpflichtung aus diesem kommando
des evangeliums verbranntes entlassen
und so dass diese jetzt in einer team
stellen die die höhere gerade gehört
haben wir ganz deutschland verfügbaren
zurück tieren können auch zu ihren
familien zurückkehren können
diese kurse ab den er gemacht hat war
beeindruckend wenn man auch mal die
ansprachen genau analysiert und war der
größte teil dieser ansprache war das
aufzählen der verschiedenen einheiten
die an dieser operation beteiligt waren
ich möchte das auch noch mal betonen
dass die fallschirmjäger
gegen spezialkräfte
besonderer weise genutzt als soldaten
das heißt die maschinen geflogen haben
ja auch eine entsprechende verantwortung
getragen haben aber das sind vielen
anderen einheiten die dabei waren bis
hin zur logistik und dergleichen mehr
notwendig sind bei einem solchen einsatz
auch mit einer relativ geringen anzahl
von personal überhaupt zu ermöglichen
wir haben dafür anders als die
amerikaner keine statische stehende
verwende die kurzfristig per knopfdruck
eingesetzt werden können und es bedarf
einer vorhandenen planungen diesem fall
ist sehr kurz war mit dem ergebnis auch
recht erfolgreich war um einen solchen
verfahren so zusammenzustellen und
ausbildungsmöglichkeiten untereinander
gibt es dann nicht mehr sondern dann
wenn man ihn darstellt oder wenn man den
grabungen eintrifft muss die
überstehende richtig zu laufen das hat
sich offensichtlich nicht gut getan wenn
da war der eine oder andere fehler
passiert ist das auch mit dazu dass wir
einen so
zusammengestellten und nicht vom verband
zähler auch mal auftreten können ich
glaube dass die männer und die frauen in
gießen auf durchgeführt haben insgesamt
eine sehr gute leistung geboten haben
wir vor ihnen ja schon mal festgehalten
es wäre schön gewesen wenn es etwas er
begonnen hätte insbesondere die
regierungskräfte ist es gott sei dank
erfolgreich zu ende gegangen
dort stand sicher auch daran gewöhnen
muss dass bei solchen einsätzen auch
durch ausgefallene oder verwundete
auftreten können das ist eine sache die
diese leute in deutschland insgesamt
noch ein bisschen lernen ist
9 uhr wenn ich nicht irre also wir
hatten schon vor geraumer zeit
eigentlich mit dem statement der
bundesverteidigungsministerium gerechnet
es ist noch nicht erfolgt dabei wir
rechnen eigentlich minütlich damit das
ist kommt sprechen vielleicht noch ein
bisschen weiter wenn wir jetzt gerade
noch mal die rede von generalleutnant
pfeiffer so ein bisschen revue passieren
lassen wie schätzen sie das ein also auf
der einen seite ist es natürlich ein
freudiger tag weil eben der einsatz
jetzt gut zu ende gegangen ist aus
deutscher sicht ist jetzt zumindest in
den letzten tagen aus deutscher sicht
muss man sagen daher jetzt nicht mehr zu
größeren tragödien gekommen wenngleich
natürlich der anschlag schrecklich war
keine frage aber auf der anderen seite
wurde auch deutlich es ist so ein
bisschen doch eine belastete stimmung zu
spüren weil insgesamt das hat glaube ich
auch herr pfeffer so gemeint der einsatz
nicht rundum positiv bewertet wird am
ende
also das ganze durch einsatz
preis 20 jährigen ein und
regierungseinsatz in dieser form nach
einem 20 jährigen einsatz notwendig hält
weil das einfach zum ende der des
einsatz das resultat support bestimmte
dinge was entschieden worden sind oder
auch was realisiert worden sind das ist
eigentlich eine sache diese sollte man
vermeiden
man hat auch zu dem zeitpunkt als die
letzten deutschen soldaten am 30.6 nach
ausgeflogen worden sind hat man gewusst
dass das kräfte in afghanistan sind hat
man gewusst dass das
unterstützungskräfte für den bereich des
bundesministeriums für zusammenarbeit
und entwicklung für das auswärtige amt
wie das innenministerium in afghanistan
gegeben hat und das ist auch für diese
genauso wie für die
botschaftsangehörigen
regel
drums ich muss kurz unterbrechen aber
ich glaube sie waren zum ende gekommen
die ministerin spricht
wie sie soeben verfolgt haben ist der
einsatzverband sind die deutschen
soldatinnen und soldaten heil wieder von
ihrem schwierigen und komplexen einsatz
aus kabul zurückgekommen die ersten
gedanken auch an dem heutigen abend
gelten den opfern des fürchterlichen
terroranschlags gestern sowohl den
zivilen opfern aber natürlich
insbesondere auf den amerikanischen
kameraden mit denen diese operation vor
ort seite an seite durchgeführt worden
ist und wir denken und ich denke heute
abend auch an diejenigen die in kabul
zurück geblieben sind und von der wir
gesagt haben in einer zweiten phase wir
werden alles daran setzen sie in den
nächsten tagen wochen und monaten aus
kabul aus afghanistan heraus zu holen
ich habe dazu heute erste gespräche auch
mit dem usbekischen
verteidigungsminister geführt meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren ich hatte
heute morgen die gelegenheit zusammen
mit dem generalinspekteur
mit der wehrbeauftragten mit dem
vorsitzenden des bundeswehrverbandes
schon eine ganze reihe von gesprächen
mit unseren soldatinnen und soldaten zu
führen dabei ist ganz deutlich geworden
dass sie diese soldatinnen soldaten aber
auch diejenigen die als vertreter des
auswärtigen amtes der botschaft der
bundespolizei vor ort im einsatz waren
unfassbares gesehen und erlebt haben und
dass sie unglaubliches geleistet haben
und es wird noch eine geraume zeit
brauchen für viele dies alles zu
verarbeiten
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
sehr geehrter herr general alt
ich habe und viele in deutschland im
verteidigungsministerium
in der militärischen führung in der
bundesregierung im parlament
und in der öffentlichkeit
wir alle haben ihnen und den männern und
frauen vor ort das vollste vertrauen
geschenkt und ich kann heute sagen sie
haben gemeinsam mit den männern und
frauen dieses vertrauen und alle
erwartungen die wir in sie gesetzt haben
mehr als erfüllt dafür bin ich ihnen
persönlich zutiefst dankbar und wir alle
in deutschland stehen ihnen und den
männern und frauen der bundeswehr ihres
einsatzverbandes gegenüber in einer ganz
tiefen schuld vielen herzlichen dank
herzlich willkommen
ich freue mich dass ich wieder zurück
bin in deutschland
ich richte das noch etwas anders aus
kurz
damit sie so ein paar eindrücke haben
bevor in die fragestunden gehen eine
hochdynamische einsatz mit nichts zu
vergleichen was sie bis dato erlebt habe
wo jeder an seine belastungsgrenze geht
und jeder sich einbringt um das ganze
möglich zu machen das ist eine
hervorragende teamleistung
möchte dazu auch wieder meinen dank
ausbringen eine alle die mich dort
unterstützt haben aus dem bereich der
anderen ressorts tolles team was sich da
zusammengefunden hat grandios
und natürlich auch ein dank an sie frau
bundesministerin das vertrauen was sie
mir gegeben haben die möglichkeiten die
milliarden garantien sind einfach alles
zu nutzen was möglich war um dinge zu
ermöglichen dafür meinen herzlichen dank
dieser einsatz wird mich prägen der wird
uns alle prägen und ich bitte deswegen
auch etwas um geduld und lassen sie uns
bitte auch die zeit für meine männer und
frauen dass sie etwas durch sagen können
das ist mir ganz wichtig und sie stehe
jetzt für sie für fragen zur verfügung
herzlichen dank
ja danke für die frage ich versuche das
mal von außen nach innen darzustellen
sie haben eine außen bedrohung die
außerhalb des lagers ist geschuldet
durch unterschiedliche gruppierungen das
sind nicht nur die taliban dass noch
andere gruppierung die dort
dementsprechend agieren dann haben sie
eine in drogen die natürlich dadurch
entsteht je nachdem wie die situation
dann dementsprechend sich entwickelt ja
eine humanitäre dimension
das heißt um das bildlich zu stellen
wenn sie evakuieren de in das lager
bringen in der hauptstadt flughafen kaya
dann müssen sie auch dafür sorge tragen
dass sie diese personen versorgen sind
ihre schutzbefohlenen dafür stehen sie
und deswegen muss sagt werden sie dieser
dementsprechend aufnehmen und nach außen
fliegen wenn das nicht gelingt kommt es
zu einer komplikation von innen nach
außen das heißt die tore werden
geschlossen sie können personal nicht
weiter einbringen sie können nicht
evakuieren und es spricht sich eine
situation auf die nach von außen und
innen immer mehr explosions stoff hat ja
sie haben frustrierte hoch emotional
belastete familien angehörige die nicht
reinkommen sie können leute nicht
kanalisieren und lenken und in diesem
gemenge lage die hochvolatile und
dynamisch müssen sie alles
zusammenbringen das gibt ihnen mal so
einen eindruck von der humanitären seite
aus noch 12 punkte dazu da weil das
genau in diesem bereich hier reinkommen
das ist uns gelungen durch viel support
erhalten und unterstützung viel not zu
lindern
also wasser rein zu fliegen verpflegung
einzufliegen
kindernahrung alles was sie brauchen
also die gesamte dimension die wird
jetzt erst bewusst und klar dass es
nicht nur eine rein militärische
operation ist sollen alle facetten
bedienen muss sie sind seelentröster sie
nutzen die die familien oder sie sie
animieren sie auch bestimmte dinge zu in
der kommunikation und dementsprechend
ihnen zu helfen beispiel indem ich ihnen
sage sprechen sie bitte mit ihren
angehörigen die draußen sind sie sollen
ruhig bleiben das hilft mir dinge zu
organisieren
das sind etwas damit sind diese
situation haben die dementsprechend klar
ist dass ganze geschuldet dann mit den
dingen die sie damit erleben ein
zusammenbruch der infrastruktur kein
wasser keine abwasser und
dementsprechend die hygienischen
zustände sich ausmalen können ich hoffe
dass beantwortet ihre fragen danke
keine frage
wie sehen sie die chance dass
in absehbarer zeit wieder zivile
flugverkehr an den flughafen in kabul
stattfinden kann
gute frage
die ich nicht hundertprozentig
beantworten kann
der zivile anteil des des gesamt
flughafens auf der südseite gelegen ist
zerstört er ist nicht mehr funktional
das heißt auf ihre frage konkret wird es
darauf ankommen wie schnell kann ich
diesen zivilen bereich öffnen wie kann
ich den flugbetrieb sicher machen und
alles was dazu gehört dass wesentlich
mehr als nur gebäude infrastruktur oder
technik der ganze support alles was dazu
gehört die ganze militärischen
operationen die sie gesehen haben oder
verfolgt haben verlaufende einzig und
allein über den militärischen anteil
dieser militärische anteil ist nur
temporär zwar durch die zeitlinie
vorgegeben sind damit wie gesagt auf der
gesamtschau wird es darauf ankommen so
schnell wie möglich rahmenbedingungen so
zu schaffen dass ein betrieb auch weiter
oder in näherer zukunft möglich sein
wird inwieweit das gelingt kann ich
nicht abschätzen liegt auch nicht
immerhin vielen dank
soweit also nochmal die letzten worte
sowohl von annegret kramp karrenbauer zu
diesem einsatz die letzten worte
wohlgemerkt die noch mal die gespräche
auch hervorgehoben hat die sie geführt
hat auf ihrer reise mit dem usbekischen
verteidigungsminister wo es eben darum
geht auch in zukunft zu gewährleisten
dass die schutzbedürftigen aus
afghanistan irgendwie noch das land
verlassen beziehungsweise daneben auch
nach westeuropa gebracht werden können
sie hat noch mal gesagt dass die
soldatinnen unfassbares erlebt haben
dort und unglaubliches geleistet haben
und sie sprach von einer tiefen
dankbarkeit und schult die die
bundesregierung empfinde für eben die
leistungen der soldatinnen danach noch
mal ganz kurz generale anzahl der die
führung der evakuierungs mission hatte
und er hat noch mal über die
hochkomplexe sicherheitslage gesprochen
und die prozeduren die ist so glaube ich
für ihn auch noch die gab vorher in
seiner militärischen laufbahn die
vielfältigsten anforderungen bei dem
zusammenbruch der infrastruktur
das alles hat er noch einmal
eindrücklich geschildert vielleicht
nochmal jetzt ein letztes jahr fazit von
ihnen wir sprechen nämlich noch mal ganz
kurz mit egon ramms und genau ehemaliger
nato general ramms sie haben dass also
gerade auch noch mal gehört sowohl die
verteidigungsministerin als auch den
general alt was waren ihre eindrücke
wenn sie die beiden reden noch mal so
gewählt passieren lassen also bei der
verteilung spin ist darin hat mich
gefreut dass sie darauf aufmerksam
gemacht hat dass die männer und frauen
dieses einsatzkontingentes lieber kunden
während dieser zeit unter einem großen
physischen aber vor allen dingen auch
ein bisschen hoch gestanden haben ja
oder sagen wie der general zum schluss
gemacht hat das muss auch alles noch
verarbeitet werden ist sicherlich nicht
nur für ihn sondern auch für das gesamte
kontingent für alle männer und frauen
die mit dabei gemüse sind
eine wichtige einen wichtigen prozess ja
auch bei den männer haben frauen einen
entsprechenden zeitaufwand haben wird wo
muss sich auch die zeit nehmen sie
sollte vielleicht auch im gespräch mit
ihren familien oder mit anderen
unterhalten kann dieses aus zu
baustellen auf diese art und weise den
bearbeitungsprozess
psychischen verarbeitungsprozess
entsprechend einzuleiten es wird eine
zeit dauern bis man das alles
verarbeitet hat ich kann die belastung
unter dem diese frauen männer standen
haben kann ich mir vorstellen und ich
kann mir gut vorstellen dass sich alle
liga
froh sind dass sie heil gesunden
versehen rausgekommen sind wie war das
mit der flüge storniert hat sich
möglicherweise auch erst noch in den
nächsten wochen oder 109 ausstellung ist
das sollten wir daran denken
konrad frau kann karrenbauer der
ministerin die erleichterung angemerkt
und ich wünsche dir noch mal darauf
hinweisen dass ministerin etwas
außergewöhnliches vor zwei tagen getan
hat als sie nämlich gesagt hat
öffentlich gesagt hat dass sie für diese
operation gefordert verantwortung
übernimmt und auch bereit ist sich zur
rechenschaft ziehen zu lassen wenn man
diese auch immer dass so etwas schief
läuft ich glaube man kann in der
umarmung zwischen general arbeitet und
der frau ministerin ein bisschen von
dieser erreichte wie haben sie denn
diese äußerung interpretiert was würde
was glauben sie was folgt daraus wird
sie personelle konsequenzen ziehen
es gibt im augenblick aus meiner
perspektive mit blick auf die
evakuierungs operationen keine
personellen konsequenzen fühlen
verteidigung ist das was
im bereich der außen sicherheits
produkte das auswärtige amt das leider
ist die federführung hat das heißt in
jedem augenblick arbeitet der
verteidiger zu bereinigen hinzu und das
ist ihr erfolg auch wenn manche
entscheidungen im bereich zu spät
gefallen ist das wird man möglicherweise
eine weiterführende
in dem augenblick wo die idee geboren
wurde diesen verband zusammenzustellen
und da kann ich doch mal auf dem hof
zurück den ich vorhin genannt habe er
besteht aus mehr als 30 nationalen
internationalen einheiten die müssen sie
erst mal zusammen hohen wir sind
erstmals zusammen
müssten gespräche im ausland stimmkarten
und dann können sie die maschen gesetzt
das kostet sage nur zeit bleibe bei der
aussage die ich vorhin gemacht habe sie
sind mit dieser edition für die
unterstützung der ordnungskräfte bei
anfang mai praktisch erschienen von
daten darüber nachzudenken und zu
arbeiten hätte man möglicherweise mit
der evakuierung er anfangen können weil
sich die sechste oder vielleicht auf den
ersten sieg mögliche daten gewesen unter
diesen voraussetzungen das ist alles
etwas knapp gegangen ja
hunderte party angesagt indienststellung
praktisch am 13 8
27 tage später also von 14 tagen was die
jungs operation selber angeblich die
verantwortlichkeiten und die leistung
und sind dann ist aus meiner sicht keine
kritik äußern konnte
die dann möglicherweise zu konsequenzen
führen würde grund für den außenminister
ich bin nicht zuständig für auswärtige
politik aber es gibt schon die ein oder
andere stelle wo ich euch staatsbürger
sage als pensionär um staatsbürger sage
redete die langen daran dass es anders
laufen können das ist der eine punkt
dabei vielleicht ton nicht dabei aber
doch mal die sache dass ich auch selber
bei mit dem braten oder auch und fans
sind und wir waren ziemlich schnelle
entwicklung mit der einnahme oder
überlagerung von harley machen wir
falsch eingeschätzt hatte ich hätte da
ist auch nicht erwartet dass es so
schnell gegangen wäre trotzdem gab es
auch noch in diesem monat in der
richtung eine oder andere äußerungen
sicherlich auch gut instruiert ist wo
man gesagt hat es wird noch monate oder
noch weniger trauen oder dergleichen
mehr und da muss man auch mal rein
gruppen nicht nur das auswärtige amt
bestimmt das ist tatsächlich der
botschafter in kabul oder auch personal
sicherungs personalien kabul war es vor
einigen wochen gesagt hat wer gemeldet
hat dann lasst auswärtige haben dass es
sich zuspitzt und das mit einer
schnellen einnahmen durch die gerade
waren zu erwarten ist dann ist das
sicherlich kommen müsste dann der
minister zurücktreten
also ich werde als ehemaliger us soldat
vor kameras oder auch von meinem eigenen
laptop nicht die forderung gemacht und
alles außenminister das kann ich
verstehen herr rampf ich danke ihnen
trotzdem ganz herzlich für ihre
ausführungen heute abend schön dass sie
bei uns waren und mit viel ausdauer die
geschehnisse des heutigen abend zu uns
kommentiert haben und analysiert haben
ganz herzlichen dank auch nochmal ganz
herzlichen dank an unsere user für die
fragen und zuschriften und ja jetzt sind
die bundeswehrsoldaten also wieder zu
hause der letzte flug ist gelandet nach
fast 20 jahren in niedersachsen
dankeschön für euer interesse einen
schönen abend noch mal in die runde ein
schönes wochenende und bis demnächst